>>Grace: Good morning, class, and
welcome to Online Learning 101.
In this short course, you'll
discover why more students
and school districts are taking
advantage of online learning
and what this could mean for you.
Let's see, it looks like
somebody is typing there.
Yes, 45 out of 50 states now
have an online learning program.
Okay, so this is what it might look
like if you were a
student in an online class.
Here's Robert Foster.
He's a senior at Centerpoint
Alternative High School
in Caldwell, Idaho.
He fell behind his freshman year
and was at risk of dropping out.
Now, he's taking classes from
teachers at Centerpoint face to face
and online classes to catch up.
Robert: I've taken quite a
few classes, ranging anywhere
from fitness to economics to
government, and my goal is
to graduate on time and to be
able to go play college football.
>>Grace: In Las Vegas, Lauren Wu
took AP courses she couldn't get
at her local high school.
>>Lauren: Two classes
aren't offered at my school,
and the geopolitical economics is
only offered through distance ed,
so I have a chance to take
advantage of that course.
>>Grace: And in Central
Florida, the flexibility
of online learning allowed
Amanda Gashaw to work full-time
and take community college classes
while completing high school.
Just like students,
schools are finding lots
of reasons to like online learning.
Reason number one, it's personalized.
Course content is available
on demand so students can work
at their own pace, and they develop
close one-on-one relationships
with their teachers.
>>Jhone: Online curriculum allows
the student if they have a question
to go ahead and email the teacher
right then and not wait their turn,
as you do in a regular classroom.
So the teachers and the students both
feel that there's more communication
in an online classroom when they're
not physically sitting together
than they do in a face-to-face
classroom
with a teacher and 35 students.
>>Grace: Reason number two, online
learning levels the playing field.
>>Benjamin: And without online
classes, the students in Notus,
Idaho will not get the same
opportunity to be successful
as a kid in Boise, Idaho.
There's a distinct
inequity in that fact,
that kids in small
schools have fewer teachers
who have fewer certifications.
We think that students at Notus
should have the exact opportunities,
the same credits, and the same
challenges that are going to get them
to excel in their future life.
>>Grace: Reason number three, money.
Robert Foster's school, Centerpoint,
was so strapped for cash last year
that it cut its math
department entirely.
Now, Centerpoint offers
math classes online,
costing the school just 75
dollars per student per course,
and there's the impact on teacher
shortages, present and future.
>>Susan: In the state of Georgia,
there are 400 high schools,
and there are 89 qualified
physics teachers in the state.
So right there, you know that not all
of your high schools
can even offer physics,
so how are you going to do that?
We can offer online classes.
>>Grace: Online learning fosters
the kind of skills students needs
to succeed in the 21st century--
fluency with technology,
online communication, and
self-directed learning.
>>William: The students
are going to be able
to use technology much more easily
and readily than ever before,
not only taking full online courses
but taking parts of courses online
so that you would have what they
call blended, having teachers
in the regular classrooms teaching
face to face with their students
for part of the time and using the
technologies, where appropriate,
to enhance and improve
the quality of courses.
>>Teacher: So you can call me...
>>Student: Okay.
>>Teacher: ...
whenever it's flexible for you.
>>Grace: Of course,
there's still plenty of room
to improve online learning.
>>[Holly]: Okay, you can keep going.
>>Grace: For one thing, many
teachers find it tough to have kids
in far-flung places work together.
>>Holly: In terms of designing
lessons where they have
to work together, that's a little
more challenging because part
of the reason they came to online
school was to be able to work
when they wanted to work, but
I think that's the next stage,
maybe two point 0, of online
education is to figure out how
to really fit that in and make it
an inherent part of the curriculum.
>>Grace: Still, online
learning is a powerful strategy.
Early research has found that
students perform as well or better
in online versus face-to-face
environments,
so it's probably coming
to a classroom near you.
>>Benjamin: Online or blended
learning models are going
to be a commonplace in the
future of education in Idaho
and across the United States.
The funding formulas are going to
force administrators and educators
to look outside of the box.
>>Grace: Okay, so that wraps up our
introduction to online learning.
In the materials here on
Edutopia.org, you'll find resources
and tips from teachers on how to
make the most of virtual education.
And if you have any questions, I'll
be available by e-mail after class.
Just kidding.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.